from search and rescue to search and
Recovery Crews scanned The Fragile scene
from above before carefully removing
debris
local people had made the first frantic
effort to find survivors
the area was covered in Ash and
a pop of smoke
whatever so basically from that we kind
of run out to see what had happened
and just within seconds people from the
community had just come running up the
roads Cara stopped people get load of
cars roll on towards
the building to see who could help the
explosion ripped through the petrol
station bringing two floors of
apartments above down onto the busy shop
below First Responders arrived to a
scene of water Devastation increase lock
it was a very very traumatic scene that
people came across it was a very very
confused scene as you can imagine and
there was a lot of debris there was a
lot of um very very you know traumatized
people you're already at the scene two
teenagers a boy and a girl and another
girl of primary school age were among
the Dead one man who went to help knew
all the victims how has this impacted
this Village how has it impacted you
terrible to be honest
okay
because these people were your friends
and your neighbors oh yeah yeah
I would know if I didn't know that when
he was a father or you know you know
somebody like
just shocking
the Emergency Services worked through
the night in the hope of a miracle
ambulance and fire Crews from Northern
Ireland crossed the border to support
their colleagues in the Republic
A desperate Race Against Time has turned
to disbelief this small village unable
to comprehend the scale of This Disaster
how do you deal with the tragedy of this
enormity uh family members just gone in
to a shop and suddenly this terrible
event takes place this terrible accident
and it's just like a tsunami of grief
that has hit us all and had this
community there's an eerie silence here
people are numb and heartbroken that
something so awful could have happened
in this picturesque Place Ireland's Head
of State president Higgins said every
loss and injury would be felt by every
member of this close-knit community
and Far Beyond
they're still investigating the cause
but police say all information points
towards a tragic accident people having
gone to work are just gone shopping
never to come home again